Presidenta wonderline,
cómo es posible que dé lecciones de ética
si usted ha tomado partido
en lugar de ejercer la mediación y la neutralidad
para facilitar la Paz.
Europa ha estado en silencio hacia Gaza.
Se preocupa más
de izar 1 bandera de Israel en Bruselas
o de visitar a netanyaju,
que de denunciar el cruel
e implacable castigo sobre la población de Gaza.
Y por eso, presidenta, debería de emitir
las bombas a los hospitales.
Los cortes de luz,
de agua, de energía y de alimentos
son 1 crimen internacional
y no pueden bajo ningún concepto
contar con la vergonzosa complicidad
e hipocresía Europea.
No en nuestro nombre.
La ocupación que sufre el Pueblo palestino,
denunciada en numerosas
resoluciones de Naciones Unidas,
es deplorable porque la pargeis del gobierno sionista,
el bloqueo a Gaza es deplorable.
La violencia desproporcionada de Israel
hacia Palestina
es 1 castigo colectivo a 1 Pueblo
que demanda su autodeterminación.
Rechazo absolutamente el genocidio en Gaza
y la limpieza étnica
que Israel está llevando a cabo en Palestina.
Exigimos el cese al fuego,
corredores humanitarios
y aplicación inmediata del derecho internacional
humanitario. Es necesario trabajar sin descanso
por el cese de la violencia inmediata en Gaza
y 1 solución de Paz.
No queremos más muertes de ninguna nacionalidad.
Stop al genocidio en Gaza,
no en nuestro nombre